welcome back to new rock stars i'm erik
voss and this is a breakdown of moon
night episode six the season finale in
which jake lockley finally reveals
himself to say via con dios from leyla's
new fit to i kid you not another
verified kang easter egg let us break
down all the details that you missed in
this episode and this is your last
chance to get a moon knight themed
latest obsession shirt at new
rockstarsmerch.com before they go back
in the vault forever now before the
episode even begins the previously on
segment opens with arthur harrow firing
his shots at mark back in episode 4
gunshots at jake lockley will volley
back at him in the final shot of this
finale now over the marvel title card is
earl grant's 1958 song the end with
lyrics describing how things like
rainbows and stories have finite ends to
look forward to but the speaker's love
has no end in the way that this episode
that marvel has suggested would be a
series finale has since been changed to
just a season finale since there is
obviously more of jake's story to be
told and this music drifts away as we
fade in on mark
at the end
[Music]
yeah earl sings the words at the end of
a river the water stops its flow right
as we see mark bobby dead in that water
and the audio mix works in sounds of
crashing waves along the bank of a river
despite mark floating in just this mere
puddle just a cool way of linking him to
steven's drowning in the sandy ocean
hero says i'm sorry i'd have to be this
way
mark specter
stephen grant
whoever else might be in there a little
hint that there is indeed a third altar
still inside that body the one who will
avenge these gunshots and as hero places
a scarab on his chest mark's star of
david necklace is visible another
reminder of how egyptian mythology and
the mysticism of judaism in the covering
of mirrors during the shiva morning
periods are equally important to mark
especially in his relationship to his
own reflection hero turns seeming to
hear leila scuffle
and again on his steps the audio mixes
in sounds of that crunching glass which
this episode finally drops the smoke
screen on as mark and steven see heroes
true nature hero proudly holds up ahmed
to shoptee and the followers kneel
another indiana jones reference and
raiders of the lost ark when bellock
hold up the golden idol and all the men
knelt which indy used as the chance to
escape arrow's staff now transforms into
an upgraded weapon the left side croc
head bending over to form one large croc
head leaving that back half as a blade
this whole thing transitioning from a
balanced swinging pendulum of justice to
something closer to an executioner's axe
layla lifts to scarab from mark's bloody
chest an early indicator of her final
form this episode the scarlet scarab
hero uses a staff to suck out soldiers
souls just interesting how these purple
souls float upward signaling how the
underworld isn't beneath our feet but
similar to the mcu depictions of
valhalla when odin floated off to it
it's a spiritual plane with no
directional vector to get there tarant
uses corpses to speak to layla it's mark
who's telling you to stop he's dead and
i'm talking to you through dead people
right now so what yeah the actor who
plays that soldier ahmed saeed does such
a good job matching antonio silva's hand
gestures and demeanor as tower it and
you can be my avatar harrow opens the
pyramid to enter the chamber where the
idiots avatars line up against them you
won't believe what the gods have hidden
from mankind
you're judges not warriors
this doesn't need to happen yeah right
at the end of the avatar's bodies
straighten up and their eyes roll back
showing that harrow is fighting the gods
in their human vessels yet since amit is
a beastly devourer she is more hostile
in combat that fight goes unseen but at
the end of it is avatar is left splayed
on those steps while it gets sealed
hawthorne's avatar is frozen on the
floor her arm's still reaching out her
finger's not exactly limp on her hand
there and a similar pose as the one
steven was left in so harrow finally
releases ahmet voiced by actress saba
mubarak and i just love ahmet's
character design with her crocodile
tails snaking from thick braids from the
back of her head and the faint linen
wrappings around her head and dangling
from her snout likening her to konshu a
deity also mummified though she is not
as weathered as he is whereas tawarah's
ears would always wiggle here when ahmet
looks right at the camera the eye on the
left twitches just a little bit like a
little crocodile wink ahmet tells hero
that his skills lack balance which is
something that she approves of because
that imbalance means that lying ahead of
him is some service to her and she says
i once relied on a servant whose scales
balanced perfectly
in exchange
i was bound to stone for 2 000 years
yeah the final avatar she's referring to
was alexander the freaking great whom
harrow hinted betrayed her to the gods
now ahmet is suggesting alexander's
skills were balanced perfectly so it's
confirmed in the history of the mcu
alexander the great was a successful
conqueror thanks to amit yet he was
still great in his own heart laila
releases kanchu who asks her to be his
avatar but she's like nope you need a
plan
little bug yes the way konchu called
steven nicknames like worm he does the
same for layla which also foreshadows
the way layla uses an insect for her
moniker as a scarlet scarab remember the
forger explained how layla's father
called her his little scarab mark takes
in the field of reeds
quiet yes the same words dr otto
octavius says when peter fixes him and
spiderman no way home it's so quiet
those voices
inside my head i'd almost forgot because
it is a similar catharsis for these
characters and in a world that was once
noisy has now gone silent mark goes back
for steven similar to the greek myth of
orpheus's journey into the underworld
for his love eurydice because this
series core dramatic relationship is the
brotherhood and the love between mark
and steven it's a story of self-love and
self-acceptance you
are the only real superpower i ever had
and so we get this sweet anna and elsa
moment where they're one shared heart
not they're too hard separately trying
to balance a scale just one heart shared
together is what moves osiris to open
his gate osiris of course being the
egyptian god of the underworld and of
resurrection so after passing through
this gate mark breathes once more in the
tomb mark
i feel the pain
inside of you
do you want death
but do you want life and in this montage
we flash back to that cave moment in
chicago when last episode stephen
stepped on the bird bones in that memory
suggesting konchu did project himself in
mark's memory to help him feel less
alone when he looks back on that
traumatic event and in this way suggests
he was there to decide his whole life
his breakdown outside his mom's shiva
obviously his possession but also his
marriage with layla and now the bullets
hit the ground this close up evoking
neo's resurrection in the matrix when
all the bullets in the floor this time
when the wrapping's in case's body it
happens more slowly it's that gentle
swaddling like a loving re-embraced by
konshu and then his breastplate layer
comes in significantly after gushing
outward in a heart shape markets even
negotiate with konchu and kanji turns it
from day to night mark leaping into the
light of the full moon his cape
eclipsing it in a crescent shape let's
end tower it i would be delighted to
accept you as my avatar
oh your father was going to be over the
moon when he is my father yes i met him
when i took him to the field of reads
yes tarah confirms that she did take
layla's dead father into the field of
reads i like how she says over the moon
just a nice word play for layla in her
family history being over and beyond the
influence of the moon deity that's
ruined their lives halo unleashes
ahmed's judgment over cairo and his
disciple bobby preaches what is
essentially the creed of twitter judge
everyone
and i love this one of these parents are
cameos by moon knight director moana
diob who is judging executive producer
grant curtis all of these souls feed
ahmet who grows giant size and i like
how her braided tail pushes a truck and
clears a nearby camp though it is not
clear if the people of cairo can
actually see giant amit and then later
also see giant konshu because episode 2
did establish that regular folk cannot
see konchu kick the trash bin or see the
jackal smash into stuff and that these
supernatural forms only present
themselves to those they wish to see
them and also we don't really see any
reaction shots of the egyptians looking
up and going holy [ __ ] a giant crocodile
and a giant bird skeleton now harder
than wrapping your head around all these
details could be wrapping your head
around the environmental impact of the
electronics we use every day a new
smartphone represents about 175 pounds
of carbon emissions and 18 000 gallons
of water usage so when that phone or
that tablet that laptop gets thrown away
it also becomes e-waste and a great way
to keep toxic e-waste out of landfills
is by purchasing renewed electronics and
our friends at backmarket have built an
amazing marketplace that offers expertly
renewed smartphones laptops and other
tech for a fraction of the normal cost i
have been using this sweet 20 rose gold
ipad air from back market and i love it
it looks brand new it costs way less
than buying new and it didn't turn into
e-waste that's a sweet tablet they're a
quadruple threat at back market with
focuses on price quality integrity and
trust each device goes through a
rigorous testing process by certified
professional refurbishers plus they are
up to 70 new tech and they offer 30 day
change of mind returns and a full year
warranty for any device plus with
backmarket's new buyback program you can
also sell your old tech for cash use
code rockstar and save twenty dollars on
your first purchase of expertly renewed
tech so break up with new tech and find
your next device at backmarket.com
that's back market not black market
layla emerges with our new suit from
tower rant as the scarlet scarab
confirmed by marvel you can see the red
scarab insignia on her collar and she
unleashes scarab wings now in the marvel
comics the scarlet scarab is abdulfaul
egyptian villain to a group called the
invaders which include cap bucky human
torch neymar and union jack this series
has given us hints of this with laila's
name being laila abdullah el fawli and
that red scarab on her bandage in
episode 4. also the closing credits of
every episode have shown a scarab with
her holding that scarlet colored flare
mark confronts harrow and i love how the
frame rotates on the incline of the
pyramid with the full moon behind them
amazing shot composition and blocking
because harrow has high ground and only
has to run downward whereas mark has the
low ground and must run up yet sprints
at the same speed as harrow and hits him
with a powerful knee uppercut the moon
framing this all makes it clear that
this round goes to mark giant khanshu
fights giant ahmet right as mark and
steven fight harrow in an aerial battle
now despite the trope of giant cgi
battles and the climaxes of many mcu
titles i actually don't mind it here
because as is often the case in
mythology the battle between mortals is
a proxy for a higher tier feud between
the gods leila saves mark deflecting
harrow's blast with her golden wings and
crossing her arms and then later saving
a van full of people
yes given how outspoken mamadiav was
about wonder woman 1984's depictions of
egypt it's hard not to see all of this
as an intentional dig at that movie and
diana's golden winged armor and by the
way the graffiti on the wall behind the
girl is arabic translating to konshu is
alive throughout all this i just love
the fight choreography and the handoffs
between stephen and mark stevens baton
getting deflected and then caught by
mark and then when stephen is kicked
across the alley mark's grappling hook
shoots out of that dust but it ends with
harrow pinning down mark then we black
out
[Music]
whoa so jake lockley obviously took over
here as he did in episode three with the
folks on the roof and in the transition
at the end of episode two when mark
suddenly found himself in the egyptian
hotel and probably the violent blackouts
when all those guys ended up dead in the
alpine village here when mark wakes up
he's nearly plunging that axe blade in a
harrow's head and in addition to
harrow's men now dead around them
there's also a bunch of flames that
weren't out there before cars wrecked
and burnt in that shop behind them
whereas before it was undamaged now the
neon sign is mostly out and a
fluorescent bulb dangles so we still do
not know what jake's suit looks like or
how powerful he is but presumably this
suit is capable of unleashing some
explosive targeted shock waves
possessing some kind of power beyond the
healing powers in the weaponry of mark's
ceremonial attire actually that third
look might be visible for a few frames
in the credits right before we flash the
hooded moon knight another form with
frayed mummy wrappings over the face but
with the eyes left exposed that could be
what jake lockley looks like when he
takes charge layla and mark uses fella
to immortalize amit but mark cannot
bring himself to execute harrow so
kanchu agrees to release them we think
but stephen wakes up in harrow's office
where they now see the blood pulling
from his sandals the implication might
be that harrow's feet in the series were
always bleeding but mark steven all of
us did not see it until now kind of like
in the sixth sense malcolm sees what he
wants to see and that color red's true
significance is not clear until it all
comes into focus but this office i
believe is not real not like the rest of
the hospital that we saw in episode five
the hospital was their perspective of
the duat underworld ship rather this
room is their organizing principle
representing their subconscious
self-doubt so last episode they would
suddenly teleport back to this room when
one of them suffered a mental break so
this ned flanders is not hero it's the
embodiment of doubt that heroes
antagonism represents for them and now
that they see hero as a bleeding mortal
he truly is they are no longer trapped
under their doubts control they control
it so steven says goodbye with
both his closure with their mum but also
their departure from ahmet's spirit
inside harrow and the final scene takes
mark and steven back to where they were
in their opening shot of the series
waking up in their london flat once
again listening to angle bear humble
deeks a man without love the tank now
has two goldfish reflecting mark and
steven coexisting the brothers learning
to share but they fall on their face
once again restrained by the ankle this
restraint and the fish when you think
about it represented one altar keeping
another altar trapped in a tank and now
jake lockley has really done that to
both of them what mark had done to
steven now the credit sequence shows now
a full moon an evolution throughout the
series now symbolizing mark's wholeness
with stephen but the post-credits scene
shows harrow in another psychiatric
hospital actually first to see a shot of
a rubber ducky dressed as a doctor maybe
a nod to him being a quack doctor in
mark's mind the way steven has always
been surrounded by sand on the series
now harrow sees sand in his coffee cup
but spills it showing the kind of
clumsiness steven would show whenever he
fell on his face getting out of his bed
but harrow still has that tattoo meaning
this is the same real life guy from the
before this isn't in anyone's head the
nurse is waved away
i beg your pardon
yeah it is off screen but jake did
something to woo or flatter that nurse
like she doesn't know where to put her
hands either she is awkward or smitten
just proving this guy to be a smooth
womanizer who asked out dylan back in
the museum jake lockley speaks spanish
an update from the new york cabby in the
comics and likely a nod to oscar isaac's
ancestry perhaps even hinted at by the
masayado sol last episode which now
plays once more from the limo but they
wheeled past this poster with a qr code
this is the same qr code that's been
hidden in several episodes this season
but now when you scan this with your
phone the page that it takes you to has
been updated to a 2019 moon night comic
in which moon knight faces king the
conqueror yeah this is the second kang
easter egg in moon night after we
confirmed ferro rama tut on the jacket
in episode three now kang obviously did
not appear in the series they really
didn't need him in the story but still
this is a moon knight producers hinting
that the history of the mcu's next big
bad is connected to all of this and who
knows moon knight or the scarlet scarab
konchu tower it may show up alongside
kang in a future mcu appearance like
loki season two maybe ant-man the water
spontaneous we'll see outside this
hospital it's called psychowitz
psychiatric hospital a nod to bill
cycloids a comic artist who contributed
so much of how moon knight looks rather
than the taxi jake drives in the comics
here he drives a white limo with spectre
plates just like the ride mr knight
takes in the comics now this might be
nothing but one of the men standing
outside has the same long white hair as
crawley i don't know if this is just an
actor cameo or all of reality crumbling
now inside the limo konshu is sitting in
there wearing the fancy suit as he does
in that same run of the comics and he
says that he was never interested in
taking leylah's avatar since his number
one is the hidden altar mark and steven
never saw the one in the red sarcophagus
jay glockly
[Music]
yes we end on frank sinatra's you are my
way of life a song about eternal
devotion like the devotion between jake
and konshu a devotion hopefully we will
see more of if we ever get a second
season of this show i want to thank you
all for joining us in these breakdowns
of moon night this season you can follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you